yeah welcome to this video playing a
great master moskalenko and he obviously
registered on icc before knowing that
you get the title in front it always
looks a bit a bit silly this double GM
okay I'm he is playing the UM Stonewall
and this is interesting the stone wall
is widely considered to be incorrect
against d3 again this white is not
committed to UM to to d4 but what's
kalanchoe arm doesn't share this opinion
he played this numerous times and even
had it in a book yeah he had some he
recommended something like this and then
97 I even tried this out a couple of
times as as black and it's not so bad
really it looks it looks really ugly but
it's not not that bad I forgot though
how I displayed okay Bishop c5 maybe
intending he five with tricks on on f 2
194 some nights III maybe and he can
play Knight g4
hmm yeah this is so not very comfortable
NYCHA Forza really annoying at the c5
idea gap interesting he knows what he's
doing at least it's so difficult to to
play
I don't know maybe this one it's not
exactly great now this is what least
possible then play the seal certainly
okay for black and I thought maybe yet
even something something better Bishop
be six but not sure this is fine is he
played this fine I think be the only
thing is he's not very well developed f
three years smooth that I'd like to play
but ok first first covers maybe this is
too slow and I should have played f3
instantly ok don't mind to go to see 75
this isn't this good should should be
you should be fined
this one on the other don't know Zach
and it's not spent too much time but
take worth a look there's two two things
hanging of the night enter and the porn
and
but take it with the rook don't know
that's some big drawback don't see it
actually I take sister of course the
more natural move but ok to 2p to two
things hanging I take here and yeah
maybe is going Bishop to e6 but ok I
have no way to to go back now this is
threatening King 56 I need to need to do
this I think King be sick psycho rugby
five ok
can just go d6 to take the poem it's a
form is hanging
this is actually really weak so f4 or
something else f4u with their or rookie
54 my wait wait wait I can play with
fire rookie five rook is six and okay
you Scott rookie six anyway yeah but I
don't turn this is the easiest check
grab another epi seven with two extra
points ok ok cannot go to e3
my bishop needs to go to sea for then it
would be very nice c4 would cover the
extra material
I don't want to go to a 3 this is a very
stupid look stupid
should be for should be good job
attacking the porn okay don't mind to
take now I have this covered buddy this
is a good Bishop understand i'll resign
yeah only fell apart but read with was a
very interesting opening really
interesting yeah maybe this mother sir
is this not good i don't know this is
what what a friend of mine played
against me when I had this espa like in
blitz games I i was trying this out when
i studied the stone wall a couple of
years ago but this is not really tricky
really tricky because if I am let's put
it on the board I went I went here it if
I go here I think I thought naija for is
this is a problem I need to play hook
everyone now if I cannot do this year at
c5 and this this this Bishop is just
trapped what am I supposed to play rook
f1 is scotty five so i cannot go go
Knight c3 and this one is even worse I
have no squares here for for the special
which are therefore is probably bad i
mean probably okay this was my idea I
thought you would just play here but
maybe this is bad to keep this idea in
the position but this is probably less
convincing now of course now i'm on d6
yeah now i can just play III he cannot
trap this bishop ok so maybe maybe made
an interesting choice i but i didn't
appreciate the points yeah but to taking
what he did was excellent yeah he knows
he's got a fine position this is a bit
early maybe but still I certainly okay I
think okay this now is a simple
loosening check yeah I now two two two
things I hanging another computer wants
to go F 3 m-f three ads maybe even
better yeah probably it's better but ok
it's it splits and now 95 yeah this is
really bad because I was 56 oh no now is
fine falling apart before has just week
in addition though he's got no no move
relief Jack Jack yes winning the same
game jack but of course he helped helps
with those moves I'm not sure if I would
have made it with the time it's a bit a
bit tricky yeah the stone ball is black
girl this is a bit a bit shaky if white
is able to to play this this kind of
stuff because you have this idea later
so let's say let's say a place in this
fashion here and i'll go if all this is
did I get this back and this is all all
all week yeah okay an interesting game
thanks for watching